interview uh September 15th
1958 uh subject one Matthew Patrick
subject Godzilla whatever the hell that
is so tell me Mr Patrick what exactly
did you see you don't understand it
wasn't it wasn't a person it it wasn't
human at least not anymore how it was
just a man in a suit no no it it it's
something else now it it mutated and
it's coming for
[Music]
us hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that has the world's best
imitation of the Godzilla
roar that was my very lame Godzilla
scream listen too is notoriously
protective of that Roar it's the best
that we're going to do all right so
we're all familiar with Godzilla right
king of the monsters been a Mainstay
movie theaters for the past seven
decades he's appeared in nearly 40 films
and single-handedly pioneered the whole
Kaiju genre and of course with that
amount of History you're going to have a
ton of different interpretations of the
character from the big budget American
movies where he fights King Kong in the
monsterverse to true lowbudget horror
masterpieces like this year's Godzilla
minus one but today I want to look at a
completely different take on the
character one that's available right
here right now on good old youtube.com a
new analog horror series known simply as
the man in the suit you're not hearing
that incorrectly it's an analog horror
series about Godzilla or at least the
human inside of Godzilla and let me tell
you loyal theorists the story that tells
is simultaneously scary tragic and
heartbreaking in an overcrowded genre
full of cheap thrills the man in the
suits covering some massive topics with
devastating themes which has only made
more impressive once you realize that
the Channel's Creator unknowingly is
just doing this all on their phone also
and uh this is just a side note here it
recently came to my attention that
unknowingly was getting harassed by a
small subset of the Godzilla fan
Community for the series and thinking
about ending the entire thing to which I
say first off unknowingly your work is
great the story that you're telling it's
mature it's thoughtful don't let a small
group of whiny butt hurt Manchild
diminish the great work that you're
doing speaking of those butt hurt
Manchild if you are one of those people
who harass someone's fan creation
because the visuals are bad or the story
isn't what you like guess what you are a
baby and you need to go change your
diapy w w Man baby go back to your crib
valid constructive criticism yeah that's
one thing that is great it is valuable
to creators across the board but sending
death threats to a kid making a fan
series on his phone because in your eyes
it disrespects your rubber suit lizard
monster guess what you're the real
monster o boy I I went a little bit
harder than I expected on that one but I
had to get off my chest you see in case
you missed it I made an announcement
over on game theory that these next 10
weeks of episodes will actually be my
final 10 weeks of Hosting these channels
don't get me wrong I'm still going to be
around working on really cool projects
in the background including a lowii
related ARG that I'm just really hyped
about but it's not going to be me
recording these scripts every single
week I talk about it in a lot more
detail over there in case you're curious
as to what's coming next but the long
and short of it is that my time as the
film theorist is coming to a close and
so you know what I'm just going to tell
it like it is and toxic fans you suck
you have ruined so many series for so
many people you are the worst go home
let people enjoy what they want without
you trying to gate keep it and everyone
else out there don't feed the trolls
ignore them they'll go away to their
lonely little holes woo kept that one
pent up for a while anyway the man in
the suit it hearkens back to the
earliest days of the Godzilla franchise
when all special effects had to be done
practically so to simulate a giant
lizard terrorizing Tokyo the filmmakers
had a real stunt man put on a big rubber
suit and stomp through miniature models
of the cities that was fighting in
however working in these suits it was a
far bigger challenge than you might
initially realize they had no eyeh holes
for the actors to see out of they
weighed over 220 lbs internally they
heated up to extreme temperatures and
they were so difficult to breathe in
that the crew often had to attach a tube
to get the actor air a tube that had to
be removed when they were actually
filming the darn thing there was even
one incident where an actor almost
drowned when his breathing tube fell out
as he was being lowered into a pool of
freezing water that right there it
already sounds like a terrifying
experience but the man in the suit takes
things a step further reimagining that
claustrophobic experience as one that
never ends as the suit completely
consumes the person inside turning them
into a mutant monster themselves but
underneath all of this monster business
is actually a surprisingly heartfelt
story about pain grief and overcoming
cycles of violence brought about by one
of the worst tragedies in human history
yeah this is one of those series friends
so charge up that Atomic breath loyal
theorists as we begin to unzip the
secrets of the man in the suit now
before we actually hop into the
discussion I did want to acknowledge
upfront that the series includes
fictionalized versions of real people
who actually existed this includes the
real actors who played characters like
Godzilla and the other Kaiju these
aren't just anonomous stunt people
however the man of the suit is also
clearly set in an alternate Universe
dealing with events that never actually
happened even if they are happening to
real people I just wanted to clarify
that because when you're dealing with
these sorts of online analog horror
series or args based on dramatized
versions of real events it's best to
clearly separate the real fact from the
fiction so in classic analog horror
fashion the actual plot of the man in
the suit isn't exactly the easiest thing
to follow everything's told to us
through VHS tapes uploaded by an
anonymous American cameraman who worked
on some of the original Godzilla movies
back in the day and it was far more
disturbing than you might think the
original actor hired to get into the
Godzilla suit became obsessed with it
staying in costume the entire time that
he was on set during breaks even taking
it home after work despite being told
not to the producer on the film says
that it's almost like the suit was
talking to the actor eventually the
actor started calling himself Goji a
nickname borrowed from Gojira the
Japanese name for Godzilla now you might
chalk all this up as an actor taking his
role very seriously I mean this guy
could very well be the Jared Leto of
Kaiju films but quickly things start to
escalate taking a turn for the worst
goji's breathing becomes strange and he
stops moving entirely for minutes on end
despite the crew's best efforts to keep
him out on track eventually they decide
to take a look inside the suit to check
on Goji but what they found inside was
no longer human goji's Flesh and Bones
had grown into the suit flesh filling
all the empty space inside his organs
rearranged and he's lost his vocal cords
though he could still see out of the
suit's eye sockets with bloodshot eyes
the suit has become his new skin his new
body the man and the suit have become
one of course instead of doing
everything they can to help this
obviously suffering man that they had
literally transformed into a monster the
production company too just decides to
keep this turn of events secret from the
public partly out of fear of being ued
but mostly cuz Godzilla was just making
him a whole lot of money they had merch
to sell and movies to make baby so the
show had to go on and now hey they had
themselves an actor fully dedicated to
the part however as the years roll on it
becomes clear that Toho has no real
control over the creature during the
filming of the sequel while shooting a
scene between Godzilla and a new monster
called Angus Goji ends up attacking his
co-star biting into a suit causing the
other actor to bleed the stunt performer
inside screams out in pain when the crew
opens up the Angus suit they find that
it too has been transformed into a
monster just like Goji Toho decides to
cover up this incident too and attempt
to tame Goji so they can continue making
Godzilla films it doesn't work they even
try removing the man from the suit with
power tools but still nothing one time
the monster even manages to escape the
studio still nothing is enough while
filming the 1962 film King Kong versus
Godzilla Goji gets enraged by the use of
an American character like King Kong
drowning the actor in The Kong costume
during one of their fight scenes in an
attempt to keep Goji from biting other
stuntmen the studio creates a puppet for
their next Monster Mothra but they don't
consider that Goji may just bite anyone
in any sort of prosthetic a woman inside
a prosthesis for one of mothra's larvae
is bitten just like Goji and Ang guyus
before her also becomes one with a suit
eventually the situation gets so dire
that the government of Japan gets
involved intent on covering it all up
and studying these mutations more
closely radioactive material starts
growing out of goji's blood with some
claiming to see eyes within that
material despite all of this Toho
continues on intent on making more
movies and when the anonymous cameraman
sees the concept art for King gadora the
next monster Godzilla is going to fight
he decides to step in and try to stop it
himself and yeah when it comes to the
main story beats for the man in suit
that's more or less it so far
unknowingly I said that the series isn't
completed yet so there is more to come
but I think that there's more than
enough here for us to dig into and
explain what exactly the series is
trying to say first things first what
exactly is making Goji do all of this
what's transformed him from an actor in
a costume into a beast well according to
one expert character in the series she
believes that this mutation is the
byproduct of radioactivity this is the
work of radiation the man in the suit
doesn't fuse with the suit instantly his
body explodes in the suit then it
reshapes itself in the suit now if you
know anything about Godzilla as a
franchise all this talk about radiation
should be making your guer counters go
off see when Godzilla was first created
he wasn't just some city-sized monster
of the week for a horror movie he
represented something much darker than
that you have to remember that the first
Godzilla movie was released all all the
way back in 1954 nearly 70 years ago and
while that might seem like ancient
history to us Millennials and Zoomers
this was a particularly important moment
for Japanese culture and history think
about this time period it was less than
a decade after the end of World War II
and the US deployment of the two atomic
bombs that devastated the cities of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki this is where
Godzilla comes from a monster literally
created from nuclear radiation from an
atomic bomb test mutating a prehistoric
lizard living under the Pacific Ocean
for the original audience of this film
the idea of of a Kaiju like Godzilla
being an unintended consequence of
nuclear waste would have been a very
real legitimate fear considering that we
had no idea what the long-term effects
of this level of nuclear radiation were
but that's just the surface level
reading of Godzilla there's a deeper one
here that not only has the king of
monsters standing in as a product of
mutation but as an allegory for the
nuclear bombs themselves as the Director
of the original film put it if Godzilla
had just been some animal it could have
been killed with traditional Weaponry
sure it would still be a threat but not
the true Terror that we see present on
screen Godzilla is the atom IC bomb the
destruction that he leaves behind it's
indiscriminate he's an Unstoppable Force
devoid of morality destroying anything
and everything in his path and leaving
nothing behind but Rubble this is also
why the powerful beam attack that
Godzilla shoots out of his mouth is
called his Atomic breath even sometimes
being depicted as creating a mushroom
cloud similar to a nuclear explosion
Godzilla is both metaphorically and
literally a nuclear weapon and this is
what unknowingly in the man in the suit
is using as a jumping off point for
their story don't believe me the
connection is further driven home during
the video suit trial we see Toho
experimenting with Goji and playing
audio tracks to see how it reacts during
one such test we hear Goji spewing some
garbled mess in what appears to be
English at first it's very difficult to
make out but if you listen closely
speeding up the audio track you realize
that Goji is actually reciting a quote
from famous physicist Jay Robert
Oppenheimer the main architect of the
American Atomic program and the leader
of the Manhattan Project now I am become
death the destroyer of
worlds the destroyer of worlds this is a
very real thing that Oppenheimer said
years after the bombings of Hiroshima
and Nagasaki showing immense guilt for
the Unspeakable destruction that a
scientific breakthroughs cause to not
only the people of Japan but potentially
every human on the planet fun fact by
the way Oppenheimer actually said this
quote in 1965 at least four to 5 years
after this point in the man of the suit
takes place but hey we've already
established that it's an alternate
universe so who knows maybe things just
happened in a different order in that
timeline regardless this is still an
incredibly heavy and important
historical quote and given what we know
about the history and symbolism of
Godzilla as a franchise there is clearly
some level of deeper connection here
thankfully unknowingly has left us
plenty of breadcrumbs to follow in
classic analog horror fashion there's
more hidden in each of these uploads
than just the videos themselves for
instance if you take a peek down below
the videos you'll find some text in the
description written in Japanese and we
can learn a lot from what's said down
there like here in the very first
episode's description it reads as
follows Godzilla may be a monster but he
seems different to me he is rather a God
I will be the meat of the Beast I will
be the host of Godzilla I will live in
this Beast because he is the only one
who can help us there is no God just me
Goji from this we can tell that the man
in the suit clearly sees himself as a
separate entity to Godzilla but he's
willing to sacrifice his identity to
give Godzilla form to merge his flesh
with the suit to become something new to
become Goji but why what's the whole end
game here well in the description of the
Angus suit incident if you translate the
Japanese you're treated to a
conversation between two entities at
first I thought this might be a
conversation between the suit and the
man inside of the suit but given that
this is on a video about Angus and how
he was transformed by Goji the two
people in this back and forth have to be
the Goji entity and the man inside of
Angus his first victim the first person
that was transformed by goji's
radioactive bite the man inside Angus
cries out in pain calling for God to
ease his suffering but only Goji answers
telling Angus that he knows that he lost
his family and that Goji can make him
whole again that he can take revenge and
kill those who wronged him and if you're
guessing that those who wronged us could
be connected to the atomic bomb well
you'd be right on the money see Ang
guyus isn't the only person who lost
family during those tragedies in the
video titled mailed message our American
protagonist is sent a VHS tape
presumably created by Goji himself not
entirely sure how Goji was able to make
a tape with his tiny little stubby arms
but hey that is a mystery for another
day the tape explains that the man in
the suit once lived in Hiroshima and
happened to be on a business trip the
day that the bomb detonated above the
city which in turn killed his wife and
children Goji blames all Americans for
his incredible knowing that they cheered
when Japan surrendered now he wants to
take everything from the Americans in
return and suddenly goji's behavior in
other parts of the series makes a lot
more sense this is why he became so
hostile during the production of King
Kong versus Godzilla it was a
co-production with American Producers
and American characters and at least in
unknowingly Universe American Crew this
enraged Goji who saw the entire
production as a betrayal of not only
himself but of Japan as a whole as
another quote hidden in the video
description says he sees everyone
involved as filthy traitors playing with
him like a toy forcing him to work with
the people who killed his family and
this anger is why the situation
eventually boils over during the filming
the script called for King Kong to win
and that's what happens in the real
world version of the movie but here when
the two Tumbl into the sea only Goji
emerges having drowned the actor PL Kong
eliminating someone that he saw as a
traitor now all of this makes for a
really compelling story and I'm kind of
amazed by how much detail and Nuance is
packed into what appears to be a simple
series of slideshows but what is the
story trying to tell us on a atic level
why did unknowingly make this in the
first place well when you start putting
everything together it's clear that this
is a tale of two parts grief and
Vengeance on the one hand the man in the
suit is clearly a tragic character in
one moment he lost both his family and
his country that kind of grief is hard
to heal but it's easy to Fester becoming
anger frustration hatred that is the
path forward that Goji pursues embracing
this symbol of the very thing that took
his family from him and directing it
towards the people that he believes
actually hurt him but to what end what
will that actually do if he manages to
accomplish his goal to exact his
Vengeance will it bring his family back
no it only creates more pain more
suffering and not even on the people
that Goji wants to see suffer think
about the people that Goji has actually
hurt in the series so far he's bitten
two actors in costumes and drowned a
third on set but all of these people
were themselves Japanese in his effort
to get revenge on the people that he
believes hurt him that killed his family
instead he's only succeeding in hurting
the people that are trying to help who
themselves were already hurting in
postwar Japan we actually see this bear
out in the crime statistics right after
the war when anger against the Americans
would have been at its highest crime
rates were among the highest in Japan's
modern history these sorts of crimes
wouldn't have hurt the Americans they're
just hurting their fellow Japanese
people but the saddest part this drive
for Revenge to extract Vengeance and
pain on America for dropping those bombs
at the end of the war it's not something
that unites Goji with the rest of his
country when he finally escapes too
studio and explores the outside world
for the first time in a decade Goji is
shocked to see how the rest of Japan has
chosen to deal deal with the pain from
the tragedy instead of a country
preparing to strike back he finds a
country that's more or less at peace as
Goji says quote this place the outside
air the cars the windows the house did
they just move on will we forget and
that right there it's a valid question
will they just forget thankfully this is
a case where we do have an answer we as
a species cannot and should not forget
the Unstoppable destruction of nuclear
weapons several years ago I was
fortunate enough to visit Japan and took
the opportunity to visit the Hiroshima
Peace Memorial Museum and it was an
eye-opening experience it was sobering
to see the full extent of what the bombs
did to Japan and it was moving seeing
and hearing the stories about what
people went through as they tried to
survive in its aftermath but the biggest
takeaway that I had of that entire trip
was how the nation chose to remember
that unspeakable tragedy this wasn't a
case of look at these awful things that
the Americans did instead it was look at
the horrors of this power that we've
unlocked we as Humanity cannot let this
happen to any other Nation or any other
people ever again no matter what after
World War II Japan has famously never
sought to make nuclear weapons and
they've even gone so far as to adopt the
three non-nuclear principles promoting
the peaceful use of nuclear energy and
work towards Global nuclear disarmament
Japan's chosen to take what many
considered to be the darkest moment in
human history and they've dealt with
that grief in a way that ultimately
benefits us all tries to protect us from
our own power those crime rates that I
mentioned a second ago in the ' 50s they
plummeted and they remained low for
decades this led to a boom in Japan's
economy which in turn led to the
creation of technology that ultimately
benefited everyone they didn't let the
cycle of violence continue they didn't
just feed into the darkness and fuel the
anger they didn't become the monster the
man in the suit like Goji did and now we
all as a society are better for that the
question now is what does it take for
all of us to step out of the suit but
hey that's just a theory a film Theory
and
cut